so we have no shortage of gas lighting
in 2020 and specifically around the
pandemic but what really takes the cake
in my view is that Fox News has now
started to pretend that they never
downplayed the virus that they never
said it was a hoax that they never said
it was a great time to get on an
airplane or to go to a restaurant
because there wouldn't be anybody else
there they are pretending they never
gave platforms to any right wing clowns
that wanted to minimize the virus and
defend President Trump and they are now
trying to revise history much like
Donald Trump has tried to do and they
are doing it because they're starting to
get sued for having spread coronavirus
disinformation here's Sean Hannity
remember Hannity famously put up an
image a few weeks ago bragging about
coronavirus deaths zero
here's Hannity the same night ridiculing
everyone who took this seriously from
day one tonight I can report the sky is
absolutely falling we are all doomed the
end is near the apocalypse is imminent
and you're going to all die all of you
in the next 48 hours and it's all
president Trump's fault
here's Hannity again downplaying it on
March 9th in all seriousness I think
we've got to be very real with the
American people I don't like how we are
scaring people unnecessarily and that is
that unless you have a commune system
that's compromised and you are older and
you have other underlying health issues
you are not going to die ninety nine
percent from this virus correct that's
great with you all right so that's the
point I mean with this hearing the
living hell out of people and I I see it
again as like oh let's bludgeon Trump
with this new cloaks that was Republican
bomb throwing Trump sycophant
congressman Doug Collins very much
agreeing with Sean Hannity's assessment
but most importantly Hannity actually
calling it a hoax
now here's Hannity eleven days later
saying he was always taking it seriously
yeah I think what kind of laugh at it
another laugh at here by the way this
program has always taken the kuroh
virus seriously and we've never called
the virus a hoax we call what they're
doing trying to bludgeon the president
out there politicizing of this virus
well predictable despicable repulsive
all of the above here are other segments
from fox news including Jeanine Pirro
saying coronavirus is proof merely of an
anti-trump agenda hannity calling the
virus a political weapon the now fired
host trish regan will get to her later
saying the left is stoking chaos Laura
Ingraham saying the virus is the leftist
smear campaign and on and on and on
here's lunatic Jesse Watters downplaying
it on March 3rd you want to know how I
really feel about the corona virus one
if I get it I'll beat it I'm not lying
it's the called the power of positive
thinking and I think America needs to
wake up to that I'm not afraid of the
corona virus and no one else should be
that afraid either and then here's the
same Jesse Watters not even a month
later on April 1st pretending he was
always taking it seriously but there
were some Democrats who weren't taking
it seriously Cuomo was saying go eat out
in New York City de Blasio had all the
schools open Nancy Pelosi said bring
your friends to Chinatown and go to the
bars Joe Biden said the travel ban was
racist every column in the New York
Times The Washington Post downplayed
this thing and actually morning Joe had
the audacity the other day to say that
everybody saw this coming in January
genomic segments morning Joe did on the
virus in January 1 they booked a guy who
said don't worry about this virus worry
about the flu finally everyone's on
board young people old people left right
we're all in this together now and we
need to stay together until we be so now
Jesse waters saying he was one of the
few people taking it seriously all along
they are now gaslighting we could do
examples of this all day long and
they're simply taking the lead from
Trump this is what you have to really
understand about this entire sort of
echo
for weeks Trump downplayed the virus and
so did Fox News so did Rush Limbaugh so
did everybody now Trump is pretending he
never downplayed it pretending he always
took it seriously pretending he always
knew it was going to be a pandemic think
he said last week he knew it was a
pandemic before it was even being said
publicly and so now Fox News is doing
the exact same thing they're very
predictable caricatures in a sense truly
sad state of affairs in the country but
all of this is completely predictable
when it comes down to knowledge in facts
and thinking this was exactly what we
would have assumed that they were going
to do and of course the real concern the
serious issue at the tail end of this
whenever we get to it is that they may
get away with it they have a confident
dishonest ignorant is the the kind of
best way I can summarize it they are
dishonest they are ignorant to the facts
but they do so confidently on their
airwaves and unfortunately unless we
have a long memory they may not suffer
because of it and so my greatest fear is
of course that the death toll will be so
much higher than it needed to be because
of the terrible is terrible response
from the president and the terrible
responses that we saw from the
right-wing media that basically just
played to trump space that's concern
number one the death toll once it's all
said and done and it's time to decide
are we real acting Trump or are we
voting him out I worry that that
confident irresponsible ignorant
dishonesty will lead to too many people
saying would have been worse without
Trump let's vote to re-elect him and
that is genuinely an increasing fear
that I have because of the degree to
which that cultish following of Trump is
convinced that he's been doing the right
thing all along we'll keep following it
and trying to make the case that that is
not the situation